last weekend ludwig held a 1 million
poker tournament featuring some of the
biggest content creators on the internet
there was some eye-watering money being
won and lost and even some drama around
a notorious professional poker player
who took part it's the latest example of
gambling growing on twitch and there's a
whole lot to talk about
all right guys just before we get into
this i want to let you know that if you
or anyone you know has had a problem
with gambling and wants help there are
resources available where you live you
can follow the link in the description
to visit the national council on
gambling and find out more okay so
ludwig's poker tournament was massive
both because of who took part and the
money up for grabs there was xqc and
slime mr beast alan keating alexandra
botes and ninja as well as two
professional poker players tom dwan and
phil hellmuth all competing to grab a
piece of a one million dollar prize pool
for the most part the game offered
exactly what people tuned in for big
names playing with big money and having
some fun along the way sometimes at
xqc's expense i'm pretty sure someone
could see them in your glasses if they
wanted to i just noticed last round
yeah yeah yeah yeah you shouldn't wear
those i can see your cards throughout oh
wow you're welcome i could have abused
the [ __ ] out of that
it's time for the yellow ones time for
the yellow ones 2.0 xqc would go on to
lose almost 100 000 at the table ludwig
and mr beast took home over four hundred
thousand dollars each but after eight
hours of play chess star alexandra botes
was the all-out champion with almost
half a million in winnings
she just won over a quarter million
dollar pot with jack 10 on that run-out
alexandra votes the queen of chess
herself is dominating this game tonight
scoops a 280
000
pot and she is easy
the crazy winnings and losses might have
been the main talking point for the
event if it wasn't for the drama
surrounding one of the people at the
table professional poker player phil
hellmuth hellmuth nicknamed the pokebrat
has won a record 16 world series of
poker bracelets across his 33-year
career and took home the 1989 world
series of poker title he's quite
literally in the poker hall of fame to
put it simply it doesn't get much bigger
than this guy his addition to ludwig's
table added an interesting element to
the proceedings how would these
youtubers and streamers stack up against
a professional player who was winning
tournaments before they were even born
well as you saw from that table he
didn't exactly clean up and some people
weren't happy with how he conducted
himself 100 thieves co-owner jack
courage dunlop tweeted out that he was
initially excited to see hellmuth bring
poker to a new audience but that instead
he watched quote a grown man baby blame
everyone but himself for getting rolled
by streamers who were having fun a lot
of the drama focused around one
particular moment at one point hellmuth
was involved in a hand with slime now
slime thought that hellmuth had folded
when in reality he'd only shown his
cards
i just have no idea what to do here
show the team and help me just folded
the best hands
yeah it's just you down a show and i
have ace nine yeah
oh my god what'd you do
excellent
you showed
i don't think you should be punished for
folding your hand all right so what kind
of deal
slime wouldn't have folded and thereby
stepped out of that pot if he thought
hellmuth had folded and it kind of
looked like he did even the commentators
thought so at first this had a lot of
people up in arms on twitter who felt
that hellmuth had in fact folded and
that this was an example of an angle
shoot an angle shoot in poker is
essentially a cheap shot at an
inexperienced player the accusation here
is that hellmuth deceived slime into
thinking he'd folded so that he would
reveal his cards it's all good
for you
so phil did not fold
he did show his cards which is totally
fine in the cash game slime thought he
folded it don't run it out
and uh a little bit of business going
there
oh my god
how lucky am i
they're saying that you slow rolled this
guy down there during that hand where
you push your cards forward and you look
like then somebody were saying you pass
them to tom dwan but someone twitter
they're fired up right now they're
thinking
if you're a poker player you understand
um yeah basically juan said let me see
what you're looking at and i threw in my
cards to look at
and then uh and then and then keating
says
show it to everybody since he's all in
so i just flipped it up to show
everybody it was pretty pretty standard
of normal yeah but i didn't do anything
wrong no no angling going on there right
because that's what these the people i
don't know i don't know come on you
can't okay
and then but people are stupid so
whatever right but all the
all the poker players know that that was
normal that was a normal thing yeah well
he made a mistake he made the mistake
and put this out
yeah yeah
now hellmuth did give slime back his
money minus five thousand dollars as a
deal but there were calls from many
people that the right thing to do would
have been to give him the full amount
back given the circumstances hellmuth
said on twitter that the whole thing was
controversy over nothing but slime made
a mistake which he himself was attacked
for and that the poker world knows he
did nothing wrong some poker fans were
quick to point out that this is all just
part of hellmuth's brand that he's known
for stirring things up getting inside
his opponent's head and just generally
being the villain of the table as you
can tell from the heat that surrounds
this topic it is pretty open for debate
i've seen plenty of knowledgeable poker
people take both sides of this but
either way it's safe to say that
hellmuth didn't come out of this with
the best public image even more so than
usual now you might think that was the
end of the gambling related news for the
weekend but there was more before the
tournament xqc appeared on pokeman's
podcast one of the topics they talked
about was his gambling sqc has regularly
taken part in sponsor gambling streams
over the past year pulling in well over
a hundred thousand viewers at times to
watch him gamble in online casinos and
slot machines we've seen him win big and
lose big but it was on this podcast that
xqc shared just how much money he'd lost
in april this year
is because it's fun because it's fun
it's fun and i can afford it and if
we're doing it just because it's fun
doesn't mean it's okay
would you have as much fun gambling if
you were doing it off stream than on
stream
yeah i i'm the
i gamble every day i lost two million
really
i lost 1.85
of course 1.85 million dollars is a
pretty staggering and inconceivable
amount for most people it's a shocking
number but if you've been paying
attention to the rise of gambling on
twitch over the past year it's not too
unfamiliar big streamers such as train
wrecks have shared their losses before
and talked openly about their need to
win back and chase losses which only
worsens the problem so-called crypto
casinos like stake and rubet are popular
sites for streamers to gamble
cryptocurrencies in front of their
viewers in august 2021 twitch banned the
promotion of gambling games on the
platform but some people felt like this
wasn't enough sometimes the streamers
gamble with their own money sometimes
they gamble with money given to them by
the gambling website but the issue of
course is the people who are watching
there are strict laws internationally
around gambling especially promotion of
it to minors the very people who could
be watching their favorite streamers
doing it now with all that being said it
is important to differentiate the kinds
of gambling happening on twitch and in
the unregulated crypto world versus the
world of regulated gambling in the
regulated world responsible gaming is
taken very seriously and governing
bodies take deliberate steps to help
better with gambling problems however on
twitch not all streamers use these
regulated operators or heed their
messages about playing responsibly it's
also important to note here that xqc
said he was addicted and just like any
addiction it can spiral out of control
without adequate help in july last year
he announced he was quitting online
gambling after becoming addicted to it
and more recently he confirmed he was
still addicted and considered himself to
be ill in a recent phone call on his
stream xqc was scolded by his dad for
the money that he'd lost while gambling
i'm on stream i guess i'm sure i'm sure
now what's up
no no what do you mean what's up except
stop stop now yeah i lost some money
yesterday what about it
you're my little boy
dad stop reading stop reading and
clickbait articles man i lose money
sometimes it happens what about what's
up
solo i mean dad come on now like you
know if
they think
yeah of course i'm fine
the rs
it's important to note here that while
xqc is still gambling just like many
people with addictions he doesn't
condone it and says that other people
shouldn't do the same he said that in
his case it's an illness he can afford
to have because of his privileged
financial position there are and will
continue to be calls for tighter
restrictions around gambling on twitch
it's been one of the most contentious
issues on twitch and continues to fuel
the debate around responsibility whether
it's the streamers twitch or the
gambling sites themselves
you